Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dans ScienceClic,
les mathématiques de la relativité générale,
partie 3, géodésiques.
Dans les vidéos précédentes, nous avons
défini les notions de ligne d’univers,
de temps propre au cours duquel se déplace
un objet, et la notion de vitesse spatio-temporelle,
qui représente la direction dans laquelle
se déplace un objet dans l’espace-temps.
On souhaite désormais pouvoir exprimer l’évolution
de cette vitesse, au cours du temps propre,
de sorte à pouvoir prédire la forme de la
trajectoire.
Dans notre univers, les objets se déplacent
naturellement en ligne droite.
La ligne d’univers de n’importe quel corps,
va avoir tendance à tracer une ligne droite
à travers les différentes dimensions d’espace
et de temps.
Cela provient du caractère symétrique d’une
telle trajectoire, qui n’a aucune raison
de tourner dans un sens plutôt qu’un autre.
De cette façon, on dispose d’un moyen très
simple pour prédire la trajectoire d’un
corps.
Dès lors que l’on connaît sa vitesse à
un instant, il suffit de transporter cette
flèche le long d’elle-même, pour former
petit à petit le mouvement de l’objet.
Ce type de trajectoire, que l’on forme en
transportant la vitesse le long d’elle-même,
est ce qu’on appelle une géodésique.
Dans l’univers, tous les objets se déplacent
naturellement de façon géodésique.
Le long d’une géodésique, le vecteur vitesse
ne tourne pas.
On peut donc écrire que sa dérivée par
rapport au temps propre, est un vecteur nul.
Tout au long de la trajectoire, le vecteur
vitesse de la pomme ne varie pas.
Cette équation revient à dire simplement
que le mouvement naturel des corps n’est
pas accéléré, et donc que lorsqu’ils
sont au repos, naturellement, les objets se
déplacent en ligne droite.
Mais on a vu précédemment que le vecteur
vitesse peut s’écrire comme la somme de
ses composantes multipliées par les vecteurs
de base.
En injectant cette expression, et en remarquant
que la dérivée d’un produit est égale
à la somme de chaque terme du produit multiplié
par la dérivée de l’autre, on obtient
une expression qui relie d’une part les
variations des composantes de la vitesse,
et d’autre part les variations des vecteurs
de base tout au long de la trajectoire.
Les vecteurs de base peuvent en effet varier
à différents emplacements de la trajectoire,
car la grille qu’on a choisie comme système
de coordonnées n’est pas nécessairement
régulière.
Bien que le vecteur vitesse reste le même,
en tant qu’objet géométrique, ses composantes
sur la grille vont varier au fur et à mesure
que se déplace la pomme.
Lorsqu’on y réfléchit, la variation d’un
vecteur de base le long de la trajectoire,
peut-être décomposée comme la somme de
ses variations le long de chacune des deux
coordonnées, cela multiplié par la vitesse
de la pomme, car plus la pomme se déplace
vite, plus vite le vecteur de base va varier.
Pour chacune des deux coordonnées on obtient
alors une nouvelle grandeur qui correspond
à la variation du vecteur de base le long
de cette coordonnée.
Cette variation s’exprime comme un vecteur,
qui correspond à la dérivée du vecteur
de base par rapport à la coordonnée en question.
Ce vecteur est très intéressant, car il
ne dépend plus de la trajectoire, du temps
propre, mais directement de la structure de
la grille elle-même.
Ce nouveau vecteur peut être exprimé en
fonction de ses composantes, que l’on notera
par la lettre gamma majuscule.
Dans notre cas à deux dimensions, ces composantes
existent en 8 versions différentes, 2 composantes,
pour 4 vecteurs différents.
On appelle ces nombres les symboles de Christoffel.
Ces symboles de Christoffel sont des quantités
essentielles à la relativité générale
car ils traduisent les changements que subit
la grille le long des coordonnées.
Ils contiennent par conséquent des informations
cruciales sur notre système de coordonnées
lui-même.
En réécrivant l’équation précédente
à l’aide des symboles de Christoffel, on
obtient finalement l’équation des géodésiques.
Cette équation, très importante, nous permet
de calculer pour chaque composante de la vitesse,
son rythme d’évolution à mesure que s’écoule
le temps propre.
L’équation des géodésiques permet ainsi
de prédire le futur et le passé du mouvement
d’un objet, dès lors que l’on connaît
sa vitesse à un instant, ainsi que la valeur
de chaque symbole de Christoffel, partout
sur la grille.
Pour résumer toutes ces idées, imaginons
non pas un espace-temps, mais simplement la
surface de la Terre.
On décide de quadriller la planète avec
un système de coordonnées latitude / longitude
qui à première vue nous semble parfaitement
épouser la géométrie.
Imaginons maintenant qu’un avion se déplace
en ligne droite.
Lorsqu’un objet se déplace toujours tout
droit, sans jamais tourner, sa trajectoire
forme ce qu’on appelle une géodésique.
Ici, sur la surface de la Terre, la géodésique
correspond à un grand cercle tout autour
de la circonférence.
Sur cette trajectoire géodésique, l’avion
se déplace toujours tout droit, son vecteur
vitesse ne change pas d’orientation.
Il ne subit donc aucune accélération.
Pourtant, lorsqu’on mesure ses coordonnées,
on a l’impression que sa trajectoire est
courbée.
Ses coordonnées n’augmentent pas de façon
constante.
En réalité, sa trajectoire est parfaitement
droite.
Le problème ne vient pas de l’avion, mais
de notre système de coordonnées.
Ce sont nos coordonnées qui sont courbées.
Leurs axes ne représentent pas réellement
des lignes droites sur la sphère.
Par rapport au vraies lignes droites, les
géodésiques, les cases de notre grille ne
sont pas droites, elles tournent.
En partant d’un vecteur de base, et en le
déplaçant sur la grille, on peut mesurer
de combien ce vecteur a varié, à l’aide
d’un nouveau vecteur.
Ce sont les composantes de ce vecteur, qui
mesure la variation du vecteur de base, que
l’on appelle les symboles de Christoffel.
Les symboles de Christoffel permettent ainsi
de mesurer l’écartement de nos coordonnées
par rapport aux vraies lignes droites.